GABRIEL GERVAIS, prés. et chef
de la direction, CF Montréal
par notre volonté de donner
à Sandro Grande une deuxième
chancercrcrce.... est
d'admettre aujourd'hui
que ce fut une erreur.
- Le CF Montréal était
de réhabiliter Sandro Grande.
L'équipe s'est laissée
nvnvnvaincre par sa maturité
acquise dans les dernières
années, ainsi que la teneur
de son CV.
technique, point de vue
développement avec les jeunes,
point de vue commentaires
des parents qui avaient
aucun problème de... d'envoyer
leur enfanrarararararararararar,
unanime et entérinée par
Joey Saputo, a été annoncée
hier, mais le principal
intéressé a été congédié
presque au même moment.
l l l l l l l l l l l l l l l é
lui ont coûté son poste.
Après l'attentattrtrtrtropolis
en 2012, il a notamment partagé
ceci : "Le tireur a manqué
sa cible", faisant référenceese.
- Les références qu'on a eues...
- Le clut t t t donc ravisé,
en s'excusant d'avoir
manqué de sensibilité.
Cette volte-face a notamment
pour qui cette histoire
- Les références qu'on a eues...
- Le club s'est donc ravisé,
manqué de sensibilité.
Cette volte-face a notamment
lulululuée par François Legault,
pour qui cette histoire
rappelle toute l'importancel'at.
ISABELLE CHAREST, ministre resp.
Sport, Loisir et Plein air, Qc
- Moi, ce que je dis, c'est
qu'on a une responsabilité
comme société et je pense
que c'était le geste à poser.
- Les commentaires de Grande
ont suscité une avalanche
de réactions.
PAUL ST-PIERRE PLAMONDON,
chef, Parti québécoisgegegegeget
à une tentative de meurtre,
donc uatatatatation publique
à la haine.
MARWAH RIZQY, députée, PLQ,
Sarérérérérérérérérérérérérérére
de sa vie lui a été volée
paenenenenentat politique.
Et par la suite, on a un homme,
M. Grande, qui s'en va faire
- Pour Valérie Plante, la haine,
le racisme et la misogynie n'ont
pas leur place. Elle espère
d'incarner les valeurs
de respect et d'inclusion.
Le président du CF
avoue avoir été surpris parUnUnt
prévisible, selon certains. Ici,
Radio-Canada, Montréa